oh I'm welcome to Friday hurry because
you're standing on my hair no no go say
welcome to friend IRA hi guys welcome to
friary if you don't know if I diary
it's gonna make that noise you don't
know if I Diaries I look back at my week
and everything I've done in vlog for him
so let's look back at some of the things
I've done this week oh yeah anyway good
morning it is 5:30 and I'm gonna go do
it
Access Hollywood live and Wendy and
Britney right here doing her makeup
they're the true champions of today they
got though what time did you guys get no
like three too early o'clock Tuesday and
now we're all in this together and the
Sun is isn't even hanging out the sun's
sleeping great Tuesday Tuesday yeah if
we made it to Access Hollywood the
glamour glamour
[Music]
we're prepping for Abby Lee Miller how's
everyone feeling so yet this is
everyone's very tense and excited we're
scared before I feel like every time I
film you guys it's just quiet stares
looking at the camera I swear they're
all very excited and creative oh yeah
hello guys it is Tuesday 6:05 p.m. and I
am leaving oh my god what is that dog I
am leaving the graceshow house oh it's
just they're working on the creative for
the episode tomorrow that we are
shooting with Abby Lee Miller from Dance
Moms mamrie's gonna be on the show with
me because she's a huge Abby Lee Miller
and Dance Moms fan and I need as much
moral support as I can because if you
guys know anything my Abby Lee she is
intense
at least on TV who knows what she's like
in real life but mamrie and I are
choreographing a dance for her an
original piece that we want her approval
of an interpretation of so we are just
working on the choreography now and we
worked on it for like ten minutes and
I'm sweating and tired
oh I can't wait so now I'm going home to
be with the maniac goose my dog and to
work on a video for Wednesday which
hopefully you will have seen by the time
this video goes up cool how are you oh
that's interesting
happy Wednesday it's a shoot day very
exciting it's me and the steamer Abby
Lee Miller it's gonna be here in a few
hours and I'm losing my goddamn mind you
know where she's gonna be this is the
calm before the storm
she's a storm she's just she's gonna be
great oh my god freaking out her makeup
is done this one's getting some hair
makeup brand grandma's here now that
Trish got you back there's a lot of
people here that have birthdays around
these last couple days or tomorrow so
cake cake is going to get cake this is
the part of the show where we'll gather
in the room silently look at each other
[Music]
you guys it's Wednesday night we just
finished filming not just an hour so
I'll go with Abby Lee Miller and Paul
Scheer for this week's episode of place
so the grace Helbig show hashtag great
show that's happening okay I just
unwrapped this whole giant bed that I
got you brand-new bed
but no you want to be in this little
alcove between got it okay I also
apparently the other night I had an
Amazon frenzy because all of these fun
buddies showed up today oh my god you
guys
Abby Lee was amazing it was amazing this
episode's gonna be so great
unfortunately we run at the same time as
the Bruce Jenner two-hour interview with
Diane Sawyer but ah it was just it was
so great I'm so Paul sheer nicest human
being gosh so nice this episode so gray
and also I'm so tired
yeah hello fry diary it is Thursday and
I'm running errands and then I'm going
to the show house to go over the edit
for this week's episode yay and to get
my hair done that Whitney JD is because
Friday night I leave to go to DC and
then to New York for next week for
things and stuff in shenanigans and fun
times so let's go watch people edit
we're multitasking so hard today I met
the show house going over the edit for
tomorrow night's episode Wendy's here
dyeing my hair who's facing that and
we're getting ready to shoot another
episode tomorrow but Shane Dawson and
Hilary Duff but now it's time for lunch
[Music]
yeah we're making progress and this man
they go out to drinks one night they
kind of get drunk they come back she
stays over it's like amazing and she's
like so excited so happy wakes up in the
morning he's like okay I have to go to
work you can stay here as long as you
need so he leaves blocks the door behind
him
she's like so she goes where anything
this week's episode the show like hey
Tigers happy Friday I'm getting ready to
go to the show house to film another
episode of that show today with Shane
Dawson and Hilary Duff who I'm super
excited about how excited are you
yep see look I'm editing Friday right
now and I forgot to put it in a clip
that lets you guys know that this Monday
tickets will go on sale for another
round of death to the DA no filter shows
we're not gonna tell you exactly where
we're going with the shows yet so get
ready on Monday all will be revealed
mamrie Hart Hannah Hart I some more no
filter shows coming your way
Monday so pumped why why oh I'm on the
floors of trying to exercise and be out
boosts hates me being a healthy person
thanks for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed the escapades this week and
don't forget to watch the great puppet
show 1013 I guess this week our Abby Lee
Miller from Dance Moms
and Paul Scheer and it's subscribe if
you like this subscribe if you like that
should leave a comment I don't know
no it just coming here done just come in
here done ah